We know that we're going to need to complete the square to this equation for a
parabola that's in standard form right now to be in vertex form eventually. So
the first step to do that is to first check out whether or not the expression we
have on the right side of our equation, the expression involving x, is in fact a
perfect square right now. To my knowledge there's nothing that we can multiply
by itself, or at least nothing pretty, to get this. So we're going to add 15 to
both sides so that we can pick our own constant complete the square with On the
right side. So that gives us y plus 15 equals negative 6 x squared plus 20. And
since we have a leading coefficient over here that is not equal to 1 I need to
factor out that leading coefficient so that the right side of our equation
eventually has the form of a coefficient times some binomial where x with the
coefficient of 1 is the first term. So I simply factor out the negative 6 from
both terms on the right side. Then we need to figure out what constant term to
add. This expression inside the parentheses, to make it a perfect square. Since
I know that when I have a binomial squared, the coefficient of the middle term
is just twice the number that we have as the second term in the binomial. We can
find the constant that we're adding to the end by dividing The coefficient of
the x to the first term by 2, then I need to square it since I have C squared as
the coefficient on the end over here in our multiplied out polynomial. That
gives me 25 over 9. Subsets belong inside the parentheses here, but it's not
actually the number that we;re adding to both sides of the equation. That number
is going to be negative 6 times 25 over 9. It looks like I forgot my negative
signs here. let's multiply 25 over 9 by negative 6 gives me negative 50 over 3.
So that's the number that we need to add to both sides. Once I subtract 50 over
3 from both sides, all we need to do is simplify this or modify it so we get it
into vertex form. Our final equation in vertex form then is y minus five thirds
equals negative 6. Times x minus 5 thirds squared. Where is our vertex then?
Well, we can read it off. It's at the point 5 thirds, 5 thirds.